alexandria is starting this hour in
atlanta
hi alexandria how are you hey dave hey
ken how's it going
great what's up um so i'm a 30 year old
nurse practitioner here in the atlanta
georgia area
i spoke with you actually last year in
march um and i followed your plan i was
able to eliminate 260 thousand dollars
in eight months in debt
wait a minute whole full stop way to go
and so you like to covet nursing and
made it like a thing huh
absolutely ding ding what did you make
in that
in this last year um
i owed 15 grand in texas so
probably i almost hit almost 500k last
year
whoa so how many hours a week were you
working um
so i worked seven days a week i worked
three different jobs when coveted i went
over
to new york and texas and i was making
10 grand a week up to 13 during the week
doing that
and i just became intentional because
student loans were debt i'm not
debt-free but they were interest-free
and i was just making sure i was
knocking out i made a challenge to my
family that i would
eliminate those student loans by the end
of december and on december 31st i went
live on my social media showing everyone
that i paid off my student loans
freaking superwoman yes wonder woman
something i don't know that's amazing i
mean
you didn't run hide from covid you went
running into the fire
and still you told me i was being wimpy
last year so
i had a point to prove i called you out
and you went and did that
i'm loving my advice right now that's so
cool
coach put me in the game i like it wow
you are amazing girl i'm so proud of you
congratulations
alexandria you're about to feel you have
to feel one lady said the other day
she said she felt accomplished you have
to feel accomplished oh
i feel very accomplished i sat down with
my financial advisor yesterday and he
said wow
you're you're really prepared and i was
like you know i followed the dave ramsey
plan and
thank you i feel really good for you to
say that to me that's very nice well i'm
so proud of you okay
so uh now on to the next steps huh
correct so i have a six month fully
funded emergency fund
my max out on my 401k contributions i
maxed out at the 15
so what i did was i created an
additional ira for after tax
contributions
um but now i still have a good amount of
money left over from my salary monthly
and i just wanted to know what are some
additional ways that i could invest
i wanted to become invested in real
estate but i wanted to do it by cash
flowing i don't want to go back into
debt so
i wanted to know what are some other
ways that i could use my money to work
for me
and so i can actually fully fund and
cash flow real estate
wow that's amazing so your home is paid
off now
so i sold my home and i used some of
that money to
fund my emergency account because i took
a job in chicago so i'm back and forth
between atlanta and chicago
um so i don't know if i want to buy a
home yet because i won't be in there for
five years so it wouldn't make sense for
me to buy a house and i'm not there for
five years
so that kind of leaves me where i am now
and i've already saved up a down payment
how many hours are you working now i'm
40 hours a week
okay all right wow well i'm glad you're
uh back to a reasonable rhythm now that
you had that year of craziness
wow so yeah so here's what i do i'm
trying to figure out how to apply it to
your situation when i max out everything
of course i'm in baby step seven which
you are right now because you don't own
a home so
um uh you know max out all retirement
that's available which is what you've
done and then i drop money
into just an s p 500 fund
an index fund okay
low to no commissions and very stable
it's going to do exactly what the market
does
it is the standard for 500 dow jones
industrial average these are the
measures of what the stock market's
doing and so it's going to follow the
market
and that's what i do i park it there
until there's enough in that account to
buy the
piece of real estate that i'm wanting to
buy okay and i pay cash
for it out of that and so it's gonna
it's gonna be more volatile
obviously than a uh a cd or something
like that but it's also gonna make about
10 times more
if it sits in there a year or more too
the increases in
value are taxed at the capital gains
rate which in your case is 15 percent
um and instead of your ordinary income
rate which is probably 35
and so you get less taxes on it if it
sits in there a year on the growth
portion
and um you don't have any taxes on it
hardly because it's got
low turnover ratio until you pull it out
and so if it sits there three or four
years it's not going to create
taxes for you and um so
i i would i would tell you not to start
buying real estate until you've decided
which city just like you don't want to
buy a house until you decide which city
so
let's let's figure that out so this is
just a good place to park a pile of
money to buy your next house with cash
and then maybe buy your first rental or
two once you've decided which city
you're gonna settle into but you are a
beast girl
you're amazing absolutely incredible
yeah
again just you know she takes that that
statement that she made to her parents
you know her
family and she hit it i mean that is
there's gazelle intense and that's like
super gazelle yeah well i mean i call
her i call her wimpy and she's like i'm
gonna show you old man
which i love a good yeah you're right
she put the old chip on her shoulder
right
yeah wimpy this yeah it's the truth
it's like tom brady you know six drop
six round draft pick he's like i'll show
all you teams
i mean that is awesome and uh she's
amazing
that what a great seven days a week
three jobs
that encourages me to call more people
wimpy i'm just saying
[Laughter]
who among us doesn't need a nice little
chip right
some people don't like the chip on the
shoulder i think a lot of great men and
women have done things with chips on
their shoulder
that i mean five hundred thousand
dollars
as a nurse yeah in one year yeah yeah oh
unbelievable three jobs i mean she went
to texas she went where the workers
ran into the fire that's what i liked
she said right where the money was the
work was
homework like crazy wow yeah
extraordinary story that's uh and paid
off 200 000
worth of debt so i am and you know isn't
it interesting how we both live
someone listening to this who uh was a
nurse
and never left their home for 12-14
months
and their homes getting foreclosed on
because they lost their job at the
hospital
because they're not doing any elective
surgeries same exact industry
same exact economy same exact pandemic
and one goes and makes a half million
dollars another one loses their home
it's just that's just human nature is
amazing it really is you know we
you and rachel cruz and i we did this
big event
uh message of hope and the big message
from all three of us was control the
controllables let me tell you something
alexandria said i can control this she
went after it